hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei the beast folge 24
ist damit um gespielt wir haben versucht
den bug den komischen lecter
wegzukriegen haben nicht komplett
geschafft aber wenn jetzt einfach als
lösungsvorschlag genommen dass er hier
der darf nicht mehr dadurch laufen
schlagen kann ich auch nicht mehr das
hat auch ein bisschen recht
aber obwohl neues ging aber du bewegst
bei mir ein bisschen länger
naja sind halt so sachen da muss man mit
leben damals gedacht dass ich noch durch
die portale gehe er erstmal nicht woran
es liegt wissen wir nicht weil jetzt mal
alles geklappt vielleicht liegt an der
pforte kann wir wissen es nicht
immer wenn ihr irgendwann twist wenn ihr
allgemeinen irgendetwas flüstern
schreibt es einfach in die kommentare
also meine vermutung ist einfach da du
den server über den pc host ist es geht
ja nicht anders
ja ich meine denke einfach dass es das
ist ein internet- oder was ich probiere
noch mal durch dieses portal zu gehen
ihr dadurch jetzt geht's okay ich meine
sachen schon mitgenommen drüben weil ich
das total angefressen oder so ich will
jetzt einfach weg bringen also war ich
um mein berg nimm einfach mal blau oder
mit dir in den links war in den tunnels
bei mir auch schon ein bisschen alter
leistet hut ist an der im internet nehme
ich an einem internet liegt nicht ist
liegt an menschen und minecraft ich
meine es liegt ja nicht sondern es
ruckelt einfach nur ein fristen öffnen
kann ich ganz normal so egal ich wollte
jetzt mich erst mal ich wollte es mal
die nachricht zu ende weiterlesen rom
ist es direkt erwartet mich mal ganz gut
angekommen
okay das ist glaube ich gehe ins bett
und zwar weil ich die nachricht weiter
lesen und zwar meinte er dass werth
bleibt halt alles mitnehmen sollen bis
auf psycho um aluminium amber und
monazit das bei mir nicht auf jeden fall
braucht mit diamanten und kopper
so da meinte er pro tipp zum anfang
solltest du so viel wie möglich
redstone eisen gold zinn und kupfer
sammeln
schau dir zuerst die rezepte der
folgenden sachen an maze runner electric
hoeneß generator und halt ihr holt dir
mindestens so viel dass du diese geräte
bauen kann es also so viele sachen solch
mindestens haben wie monsters hierbei
ich kann ich bin seit nehmen uns da also
du liegst du sagst du können das wetter
war ich auch und zwar meine der die drei
sachen sollten auf jeden fall bauen nun
packst du nur soviel ärzte in den ofen
die du brauchst um die drei geräte zu
machen nun hast du die drei geräte
gebaut und stellt sich folgendermaßen
auf also links den nächsten mit den
elektra den generator und rechts sehen
electric arc furnace so den rest der
erste papst in den mails retter aus zum
beispiel einem eisenerz werden zwei
eisen stoppte er indes kalten krieg also
aus einem eisenerz doku werden zwei als
entstaubt sozusagen als im staub gar
nicht gehört aber soll es wohl geben die
jeweils wieder in einen eisenwaren was
auf das im krippenalter dem was willst
du mein haus erstmals ruhe noch drin
also diesen alten staub kann man dann
wieder umwandeln
und das heißt dass ein spac r2 speck
staub sind und das sind zwei städte
waren also kann man das ja wirklich
immens mit weitermachen
den stau packt man dann in den electric
hoeneß der in ganz recht steht und dann
brennt man den und um den mails raider
und elektrik fans mit strom zu versorgen
muss man sie beide an den generator
packen der in der mitte steht der muss
in der mitte stehen der generator
produziert dann den strom so lange kohle
in den drin ist und ganz wichtig ist
dass wenn man keinen strom benötigt wird
sondern die kohle daraus ziehen weil er
sonst einfach weiterläuft
also danke an der real semmel der mir
das auf jeden fall geschrieben hat
ich werde jetzt erstmal bauen wir haben
hier diesen sieht mode glaube ich reset
north face raiders der base rate ich
nicht mit
wo kann es suche eingeben nach unten
sich jetzt einfach drauf
dafür brauche ich pflaster steine
maschinen blog also erstmal feuersteine
und feuersteine stein wissen wir über
die kriege einfach ja aber was ist ein
elektronik circuit drauf dafür braucht
man kompakt alter dafür braucht man
folglich heißt es müssen wir brauchen
den kupferkabeln kupferkabel dafür
braucht ihr kupfer barren und rubin
also ich würde sagen dass du dich um das
ding muss und ich muss mich erstmal
wieder so ok
an den versuchen wir es erstmal super
make it compact für kay hoffmann fr 8
ihren schweiß auch kräftiger ich weiß
nicht woher kommt er doch immer
geschrieben
es gibt also bäume die so gut wie
boykott ist die gummibäume hatte die
machen halt rabatt gummi also es gibt
aber wieso bäume die kannst du angst
hast oder so mit irgendwas kann man aber
auch irgendwoher kraft mit die chinesin
und holzkohle und minimum stellen auch
wtf also been hartmann macht man macht
es peanuts rubber oder so
heute wird er sagt wir sollen da wir
sollen beschwert euch dass wir noch
nicht genug von diesem zeug gemacht
haben aber das ist ja bei uns erkennen
also wir versuchen es jetzt also ich
wäre jetzt einfach mal mein kupfer hier
klar erklären würde ich wohl aber ich
war aber für die kabel wie krieg ich
aber weiß man offen damit ich meinen
behaupten ein bisschen was machen kann
wie krieg ich aber ach ja rabatt
recycling ach es gibt ein rabatt wird
ja es ist auf jeden fall aber wie sieht
es da raus aus dem aus dem wasser also
ich würde ganz gerne erstmal meine level
irgendwie umpacken das heißt ich wäre
dafür auf jeden fall jemand jemanden
verwenden wie macht man immer in chapman
table nein du bist auch keine diamanten
finden wenn dadurch das ist erstmal viel
wichtiger
okay in schackenthal machst du mit
papier also büchern
du brauchst doch vorher diamant axt als
kannst du dich mal die hand hatte weil
du brauchst obsidian das heißt du wirst
etwa drei diamanten haben um die achse
man muss sich ja nicht im krieg gibt
auch einen weil man kann irgendwie alles
klingt anders trinkt sie die absicht
gehabt ihren kräften mit eichenholz und
einem minimum stein messen minimum stein
die kann man irgendwie domino stein der
der kann alles machen
der buch hat muss ein minimum scherben
und ein träger stein - haben wir auf
jeden fall einige und die träger steine
die macht man hört zu die träger steine
macht man aus einem goldbarren vier
eisenbahn unter ganz normalen steyr
kümmern du dich bitte darum
ok mache ich das gerade hier versuche
ich das andere irgendwie hinzukriegen
okay ein eisengitter nämlich ob gott
also leute damit sind jetzt erst mal
locker 30 bands beschäftigt weil er
meinte der meinte auch das dürfte sich
zum anfang beschäftigen ja das
beschäftigt mich okay als ich hätte
jetzt noch keiner beschwert dass wir uns
nicht damit beschäftigen butt butt ich
werde die aktie nehmen und dann werde
ich mir hier also mini moke leider außen
wie viele minimum scherben habe ich denn
das minimum ich habe euch aber ich habe
zwei minimum scherben
wie kannst du auch in meinem ich hab
drei mit scherben privat ich könnte
vielleicht ein minimum stein machen wenn
es hochkommt
ich habe fünf minuten nochmal man
braucht 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2349 kisten
einfach gucken ja ich werde nach italien
ist ein bisschen das leder
das ist okay überhaupt 85 dann gehst du
welche hast okay leute dann wenn wir
einfach produktiv und würde einfach
sagen naja hier machen wir die richtige
einer super parade
denn jetzt sich auch wieder am stück
aufnehmen
das heißt ja die mache ich noch mal
bücher ok ich hab' ich habe mir so ein
veganes und macht mit so einer
alternative die schmeckt nicht ganz so
lecker ich habe es mal ausprobiert aber
fest für die leute passiert sieht aus
wie käse riecht bisschen so aber ich
werde euch schön spaghettiessen hoffe
meine mutter macht dass er die hat noch
nicht geantwortet
also bleibe habe ich zwei diamanten habe
ich auch obsidian brauche ich du hast
etwas eine mini-em du hast drei minimum
sterben das heißt wir haben jetzt acht
genauso wie wieder brauchen
geil programm nicht 3 ich glaube ich
habe hier hinter welcher den kisten ich
habe davon zu der befehle gefunden habe
ich die rausgeholt leute dann auch
ungefähr 5 machte mal warte ich möchte
mal kurz zeigen was ich jetzt eben kraft
und zwar ist das open air sommer 582
minimum stellen machen und das heißt
wenn zwei obsidian machen aber wir
brauchen drei obsidian oder weil man ja
noch mehr wie viel macht wir brauchen 40
jahren war was sie gerade eine hand
halte verzaubert etwas drüber tisch was
das das ist ein ehrenvolles den brauchen
wir ganz unten darüber brauchen wir drei
rief einteilen und darüber eine batterie
dann haben wir ein generator als ideen
habe ich auf jeden fall schon mal acht
uhr es gibt ein anderes rezept dafür
braucht man maschinen blog hier macht
man maschinen doch dafür braucht man
rief ein tier macht man den rivalen da
muss man einfach so eisen verbrennen
ganz einfach dass es sich ok verbrechens
einem eisen nichteisen hast du dich
irgendwie das duo obsidian zusammenhang
zu seinem kriegst kann ich versuchen
noch ein paar von diesen roten mini moke
scherben zu sammeln wissen schon dass
ich meine das ist schon durch das portal
das alles geholt
da waren wir noch im bett batterie das
würde ich gern mal wissen was er da ich
könnte jetzt 22 obsidian könnte
theoretisch ausmachen
wie würde es zwei obsidian machen